A family has to sacrifice one of their own
to save the world.
Can they do it?
Here's what happens after three people hear
a Knock at the Cabin.
Knock at the Cabin centers around a choice
that's posed to couple Andrew and Eric, and
their young daughter Wen.
Four strangers arrive at the cabin where Andrew,
Eric, and Wen are staying and take control
of the house.
They tie up Andrew and Eric and tell them
that the four of them have been united by
a shared vision of an apocalyptic event that
will end humanity if a choice isn't made.
Andrew, Eric, and Wen are tasked with picking
which one of them will be sacrificed to stop
the world from ending.
Every time the family says no to the sacrifice,
one of the four strangers dies, and a deadly
plague gets unleashed on the world.
If it gets to the point where all four of
the strangers die, then Andrew, Eric, and
Wen will live only long enough to watch the
rest of the world burn around them.
It's a dilemma that at one point is described
as an impossible choice, and it leads to bloodshed
as Andrew and Eric each wrestle with believing
the strangers and finding a way out.
The central choice in Knock at the Cabin is
an example of a common ethics thought experiment
called "the trolley problem."
This scenario imagines someone being told
that a trolley's brakes have failed and it
is barreling towards a group of people tied
to the tracks.
This bystander has the chance to intervene
and flip a switch that would send the trolley
on an adjacent track, where it would kill
just one person.
In Knock at the Cabin, Andrew, Eric, and Wen
deal with this dilemma.
It's fitting that Leonard, the leader of the
four strangers, defines this as an "impossible choice."
After all, it's not just about numbers.
These three characters are forced to measure
the weight of their own lives against the
lives of anonymous strangers.
Knock at the Cabin elevates the trolley problem
to a grander and more emotional scale, which
is partly why the film is so engaging and
relatable.
As Eric and Andrew refuse to make the choice
and the strangers' deaths unleash horrifying
plagues on humanity, viewers get to see Andrew
and Eric's life together before this encounter.
A series of flashbacks shows Eric and Andrew
going to adopt Wen, Andrew being attacked
at a bar by a homophobic patron, and the three
of them arriving at the cabin.
So, what's the importance of these flashbacks?
Ultimately, they embody the reason that Eric
and Andrew simply can't sacrifice one of their own.
From dealing with disapproval from their parents
and the outside world to becoming parents
themselves, these two have been through a
lot together.
There's a deep love between Andrew and Eric
that's hard to break, which Leonard even acknowledges.
"I believe you were chosen because your family's
love for each other is so pure."
These flashbacks play a pivotal role in helping
viewers understand Eric and Andrew's inability
to make this choice, even as they are told
the consequences.
Throughout Knock at the Cabin, Andrew is the
voice of reason.
He refuses to believe what the strangers are
saying, and his strong-willed logic leaves
viewers unsure of what's real.
For example, Andrew points out that the news
broadcasts the strangers show them, which
depict apocalyptic events, could have simply
been carefully timed.
Perhaps these news stories were already in
the works, and this could just be a matter
of the strangers knowing what was going to
happen beforehand and using that information
to scare the family.
More significantly, Andrew believes that they
have been targeted because he and Eric are gay.
He thinks that Redmond might be the man who
attacked him at the bar.
His conviction is so strong that he gets Sabrina
and Adriane to doubt their own beliefs.
However, as it becomes clearer that there
might be more at play than Eric and Andrew
initially thought, Andrew's logical thinking
reveals itself to be a cover for the fear
he's feeling about the inevitable.
Andrew is arguably the most complex and compelling
character due to the way he makes viewers
question their own beliefs.
"It doesn't matter.
None of us believe you."
During the first ritual sequence where the
strangers kill Redmond in order to release
a plague, Eric notices something in the light
shining through the window.
In a quick flash, the light-filled visage
of a figure can be seen.
Throughout the film, Eric questions what he
saw and if it was real or just a byproduct
of his concussion.
As the truth is unveiled, it becomes clear
that this figure in the light wasn't just
a figment of Eric's imagination.
It's never explicitly said who or what Eric
saw, but based on the themes of the film,
we can consider different interpretations
of it.
Knock at the Cabin centers around the question
of belief and what happens when our beliefs
of the world and its rules get challenged.
Andrew's worldview holds no room for even
the possibility that what the strangers are
saying is true.
Eric is less sure of himself, so perhaps this
figure of light is a mystical being, or even
God coming down to Earth to try to convince
him that there's something more happening.
Now, for the million-dollar question: Will
the world really end if Eric and Andrew refuse
to sacrifice one of their own?
The answer, shockingly, is yes.
While it initially seems like maybe Andrew
was right and that the strangers' visions
were just delusions, it becomes clear that
they weren't lying once Leonard is the only
one left.
When Leonard is the last stranger left, he
shows Eric and Andrew a newscast of hundreds
of planes crashing out of the sky.
At this point, both the characters and viewers
realize that it's a bit too far-fetched to
believe that the strangers coordinated something
on that scale.
It's enough to make anyone believe that this
isn't a hoax, after all.
Eric and Andrew are stunned by this revelation
and are left with one more choice to try and
stop the world from ending.
Dave Bautista's incredible performance as
Leonard sells this shocking twist perfectly.
In this moment, the weight of every disaster
that's happened throughout the film crashes
down on you.
M. Night Shyamalan doesn't follow this up
with some other twist that disproves this
sudden realization, so it's really true: The
things the strangers said would happen are
happening, and because Eric and Andrew struggled
to believe them, the world is now on the verge
of ending.
"Will you make a choice?"
When Leonard finds himself as the only stranger
remaining, he decides to have one last exchange
with Eric and Andrew outside the cabin.
He further divulges his motivations for coming
to them and what he saw in the visions.
Leonard describes the visions of the apocalypse
as nightmarish and says he felt completely
helpless seeing the world burn.
That sense of dread and the heart-wrenching
idea that the ones that Leonard loves would
perish in a fiery apocalypse drove him to
lead this small group of seers.
Now, it's all he thinks about, since the world
is on the brink of destruction.
After spilling his guts this last time to
Eric and Andrew, he asks them if they'll make
the choice.
Although the audience isn't shown their response,
Leonard's actions say it all: Leonard draws
a knife and says that humanity has been judged
before taking his own life.
It's a subtle but powerful shift as up until
now, Leonard and the other strangers have
talked about the world facing judgment, which
could go either way.
Here, Leonard, as the last stranger standing,
makes a definitive statement that seems to
seal humanity's fate.
With his death, Eric and Andrew have mere
minutes to make a choice to try to stop the end.
At first glance, the four strangers that arrive
at the cabin seem like four ordinary people.
When they first introduce themselves to Eric,
Andrew, and Wen, they talk about their lives.
So, it's tough not to wonder why they were
chosen and if they serve a greater purpose.
Shortly after Leonard dies and Eric gains
immense clarity, he comes to the conclusion
that they do.
Eric believes that based on everything that's
happened and the distinct qualities that each
of the strangers has, these four people embody
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse.
In the Book of Revelations, the Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse are seen as the harbingers
of the end of time, and each symbolizes a
different end of humanity: conquest, war,
famine, and death.
Here though, Eric interprets each stranger
as a positive quality of humanity, rather
than as a means to its end.
For instance, Leonard personifies guidance,
as seen in the way he leads the group and
"It doesn't have to be like this."
But now that the four of them have been snuffed
out, humanity's best qualities are gone with
them, leaving the world open to destruction.
It's a crushing realization overall that not
only gives deeper meaning to the four strangers,
but also makes Eric realize that a choice
needs to be made.
With only minutes left until the world's fate
is sealed, Eric offers himself up to be sacrificed.
Over the course of the film, Eric has become
the most connected with the strangers and
has been less resistant to their mission than
Andrew.
That — plus his experience of seeing the
figure in the light — has opened him up
to the truth of what's happening, even if
he wishes it weren't so.
He comes to see that the only way for Wen
to live a full life is for him to make the choice.
"There was something in the light."
Eric is in a clearer state of mind than Andrew
and has found a euphoric peace in thinking
about Andrew and Wen and their future together.
Eric delivers a monologue that pairs with
a flash forward, which shows viewers exactly
what he hopes for: Andrew and Wen, both older,
laughing together.
It's the last memory he wants to think about
before his death.
Eric is ready to make the sacrifice that will
give the ones he loves a chance at a real
future in an imperfect world.
Although Andrew struggles at first, he eventually
finds the strength to shoot Eric in the chest.
Thus, with Eric's sacrifice, the choice is
made.
So, with Andrew and Eric making their choice
and Eric dying to save his family, the only
question that remains is: Was it in time?
At first, it doesn't seem like it since the
skies are still dark and stormy.
Lightning strikes all around Andrew as he
climbs into the treehouse to see Wen.
It feels like the world is collapsing around
them and the two of them weep over the loss
of Eric.
The two of them head to a local diner, where
they discover that Eric's sacrifice came just
in time to save the world.
At the diner, Andrew and Wen see news reports
about the disasters stopping: The water from
the tsunamis starts to recede, those affected
by viral outbreak begin to recover, and planes
stop falling from the skies.
Even the rain that now falls around them is
putting out fires from the plane crashes.
The world starts to feel hopeful again.
After such an intense turn of events in the
film, this reveal gives viewers a meaningful
moment of tranquility and shows that Eric's
sacrifice had real meaning.